I think my travels and speaking to more
than one language I French is my mother
tongue and I speak Spanish quite well it
does shape you of course I think mainly
traveling especially opened up my mind
my parents I had the luck of having
parents who were peripatetic first of
all as students and then as as diplomats
they work for the equivalent of the
Secretary of State they were diplomats
working for Canada's Foreign Affairs
Department so we lived in Costa Rica as
a Chung when I was a child I was also
lived in Paris in Mexico as a young man
and then I caught that bug and on my own
I continued traveling so traveling to
muezzin is like reading in a sense it's
you are in a foreign element in
countering foreign characters and they
mold you because when you travel you
necessarily open yourself up I mean I
just arrived in New York this morning
out of what's it called Union Station or
is it Penn Station and whatever it's
called here I come out in Sun Lam in the
heart of New York and you can't ignore
that you cannot ignore what's happening
to you when you travel and so it opens
you up it was a lot colder this morning
in New York than it was in Washington so
even just the weather but then all the
people the way they walk the way they
talk they're there the buzz of activity
of New York as opposed to sort of the
quieter pace of you know Tempe where I
was earlier that opens you up and then
when you encounter different people you
realize to what extent there are
different ways of being on this earth
obvious ways of speaking but ways of
thinking ways of dressing ways of eating
ways of relating to each other and it's
in a sense what that does is it gives
you options each one of us can be
slightly different than what we are you
know life is a matter of taking what
you're given and then going with it
somewhere you can evolve you can change
you can learn you can relearn and I
think traveling teaches you that and as
four languages language is an
interesting one because I find languages
can both be an open door and a closed
door so yes growing up speaking
more than one language more than
learning more than a lot more language
and speaking more than one language it
shows you comparative ways in which
things can be explained so there's
obvious differences between English and
French one thing for example that was
lost in English that we still have in
French is different levels of
familiarity when you're talking to
people so in French when you know
someone well you will say to come over
to how are you
but the two is is a familiar form of you
it implies that you know the person well
either the person is younger or or as an
intimate and if it's someone you don't
know that you're meeting for the first
time you would say come on that EVOO
you'd say vous now we used to have that
in English you used to be the formal one
I'd say how are you when I didn't know
you if I know you well I'd say Howard
Lau we'd say thou and that's been lost
and that that's a new ones that's
interesting to be aware of when you
speak French it's a little fork in the
road that you were constantly coming to
you instantly have to know how do you
speak to people in Quebec where I'm from
for example we get to to to the familiar
thou much more quickly in France you
will stick to vous much longer it's a
slightly more formal society it's more
aware of its formalities so that gives
you a sense right away of how language
can be distancing or get you closer to
people and also there's sometimes some
languages have more obviously a word at
hand to describe a situation or
something than another language and they
also have a very different spirit
English is wonderful because it's such a
cannibal English because of English of
course is a Germanic language but but
spoken by these people in this dank
little island called England but because
of Christianization because of the Roman
and the Norman invasion there's a huge
influence of Latin languages French and
of Latin on the English language and
then because of colonialism of course
the English colonized the world well
there the language has an enormous
vocabulary it's an enormous ly flexible
machine that swallows up words all the
time so it's a beautiful language
because of its of its variety of
vocabulary but what I retain from
learning French for example him speaking
French is of the 26 letters of the
English alphabet I pity the letter R the
letter R is a very sad letter in English
it has no backbone
unless you're Scottish so know most of
us when we say rural road rural road the
rural roads of Rhode Island there are is
not a very where you can play a friend
in French and me ought to hoo-hah it's
much more guttural in French oh hell
so unless you're Scottish in Seattle
roads the rural roads of Rhode Island
then it has a real personality so that's
when we're saying when I'm writing
Minnie Ramesh actually I sort of always
missed that resonant R that we have in
French so the language is an interesting
thing because it's like these patterns
of colours and you can compare them but
I'd also argue and this is the converse
side in a sense what you don't want to
hear as often I find languages are a
closed door so for example India what's
wonderful traveling in India is that
most everyone with any education India
will speak English which means despite
the fact that in the India you know they
speak over 200 languages is a millennial
a multi millennial civilization it's an
island
it's an islands it's a continent
civilization it's very accessible to
those of us who speak English because
they make it accessible I speak English
compared that when you go to China where
Mandarin and Cantonese are walls because
few of us Westerners speak Chinese
which means immediately you cannot tell
if a door says this is the bathroom or
this is the emergency you have no idea
what it says immediately everything is a
barrier so hence the usefulness of
people speaking more than one language
or a universal language now I'm not
advocating English imperialism but the
fact that is a language spoken by people
in their billions does mean that we can
reach out to people where we wouldn't
otherwise it's it makes a huge
difference when you can speak a language
and you can understand the people you
are in count
ring otherwise you reduced a sign
language and you know pidgin English or
pidgin whatever else I find what I'm
writing in different languages that it
can shape what I'm wanting to say but
only if I don't make an effort if I make
an effort then no it doesn't this idea
that for example that Inuit will have 40
words for snow and that English only has
snow is not true you just have to talk
to skiers English language skiers will
give you 40 different ways of expressing
different ice conditions different snow
conditions I think any language can do
the job it needs to do given a little
time every language will come up with
neologisms new words to to express new
ideas those new ADIZ just have to come
in and be encountered by the language
and then it will and English is a
perfect example English is coining you
know I just thought you know for example
smartphone the word smartphone didn't
exists but 10 years ago but now when we
say a smartphone we know what we're
talking about any language can do that
some are more adept at it some are more
nimble English is extraordinarily nimble
France for example a French is slightly
less sintering if you look at the
demonstrating France French in France
and French and Quebec in Quebec a
parking lot is a tense - Ian Moir in
France they're called unpacking Quebec
because they're surrounded 6,000,000
francophones are surrounded by an ocean
of Anglophones 300 million Anglophones
Canadians and in an American they tend
to resist English words coming into it
so in Quebec a sweater is our Sean died
in France they say pull over pull over
they'll use an English word that they've
Frenchified really funny one in France
is to go jogging is failed you footing
now footing is not a word in English no
one says I'm gonna go footing it doesn't
mean you can foot a bill maybe or
something but you don't go footing so
it's there the English have used to an
English word that doesn't really exist
as a word for jogging in French in
Quebec you would never say footing
you'd be laughed out of the room if you
said footing in Quebec so it's
interesting so some languages are more
adept at taking on new ideas but
fundamentally I think and this is where
writers and artists come into play
they're the ones who renew the language
and they will do when they see where
they see and when they see a need